je vous même si vous avez regardé
l'allocution de mâcon demain soir non
pas du tout est ce que je peux vous
demander pourquoi pas ce que j'ai prévu
de profiter de ma soirée sans enfant
donc pas rester devant la télé et vous
verrez les infos après sur le téléphone
voilà la vaccination obligatoire pour
tous je vous remercie
je suis pas sûr honnêtement pour quelle
raison je sais pas si je serai devant ma
télé demain soir et je sais pas s'il a
des annonces m'intéresse vraiment en
rapport notamment aux locaux vides entre
autres au salon à la réforme des
retraites éventuellement ces choses qui
vous intéressent j'avoue je suis pas
hyper sensibilisés sur le sujet de la
réforme des retraites
le coc vide sur le cosy de un peu plus
c'est sûr je pense pas qu'il va avoir de
nouvelles restrictions qui ont été mises
en place en lien avec le le variant
delta qui arrivent et qui est déjà bien
la vue qu'on a plus de 50% des cas qui
sont dits variant malgré tout je pense
pas qu'il ait vraiment intérêt à mettre
en place de nouvelles restrictions
surtout en ce moment c'est que la vie
faut qu'elle reprenne etc je pense que
chacun a son libre arbitre sur le sujet
je suis pas forcément anti vaccins mais
je pense que chacun peut avoir aussi son
avis c'est vrai que ça un retard
peut-être par rapport à d'autres pays
européens ou mondiaux sur la question de
la vaccination mais je pense que c'est à
chacun de se poser ces questions-là et
de le faire en tout libre arbitre
j'imagine déjà que ça va pas être de
très bonne augure mais bon peut-être
qu'il le faut effectivement
qu'est ce que vous attendez de cette
allocution à votre avis y aura quoi menu
qu'est-ce que ramène uda probablement
des restrictions nouvelles qui vont nous
être annoncé de quel type je ne sais pas
jusqu'où contraignante je sais pas mais
certainement des contraintes
la vaccination par exemple ça ce serait
bien ça je l'attends oui obligatoire
pour tout le monde pour tout le monde en
tout cas pour le corps médical où tous
les gens qui sont en relation avec la
clientèle
je pense en fait je vais regarder le
résumé après coup
- il va parler en fait ce serait en
train de coucher mes enfants c'est tout
simplement qu'ils invitent tous les
jours qui va prendre le dessus
en fait c'est un peu délicat parce qu'on
sentait qu'il y avait une vraie volonté
d'en sortir en fait de cette fille du co
vide et on sent qu'avec le variant delta
de chasse on va y revenir
donc je pense que ça va être un jeu
d'équilibriste entre eux on garde en
garde
ouvert pendant l'été et à mon avis à la
rentrée septembre octobre on va repartir
soit pouvoir un confinement vers un
couvre-feu
j'en pense pas grand chose faisons
depuis un an et demi j'ai l'impression
qu'on vient entre guillemets en crise
il ya eu des effets très positifs vocaux
vie il ya eu beaucoup de morts ça a été
un drame pour beaucoup de gens
maintenant on a retrouvé nos enfants on
a retrouvé deux choses et en fait on a
vécu une vie qui était qu un mendiant
donc il ya un an et demi on se disait
que celle et la forme des retraites
c'était vraiment l'actualité total moi
personnellement je suis un pacte et
parce que je pense que je travaille
jusqu'à 70 72 ans maintenant aujourd'hui
ça me rend tellement loin de nos
préoccupations du quotidien le quotidien
selkowitz enfin concrètement c est ce
que je vais venir travailler demain au
bureau est ce que je reste chez moi
est ce que les écoles ouvrent ou pas
j'en reviens des trucs très basique
après j'ai travaillé deux ans depuis il
faudra travailler deux travaillent
encore non je ne regarderai pas
quoique là c'est vrai que c'est un côté
nationale et pratique qu'un méthode
pragmatique parce que ça intéresse la
santé publique donne je devrais mais par
aversion pour mono pour m'accroche je me
regarderai pas macro je serai ma femme
regardez ensuite mais former n'est pas
un pouvoir d'écouté macro j'ai pas
vraiment d'avis là dessus je suis
vacciné des deux doses parce que je me
suis dit que comme ça j'avais accès à
plus de choses mais je pense qu'il faut
aussi respecter l'opinion de chacun et
que si certaines personnes ne veulent
pas se faire vacciner
laquelle ne serait ce pas vacciné je
peux a tellement envie de parler de lui
parce qu'ils meurent sort par les yeux
et alors moi dans mon personnage et j'en
ai marre parce que je vais vous dire
sous pratique de nous protéger
on nous infantilise totalement j'ai reçu
trois courriers officiels par la poste
pour m'inciter à faire vacciner marquer
bon c'était l'hymne des services de
santé j'ai eu 2 2 messages également sur
mon portable pour que je n'oublie pas de
me faire vacciner parce que certaines
manches et en danger de mort tous les
matins quand je prends l'ascenseur dans
mon immeuble
et pour finir j'ai eu un coup de fil sur
mon fixe alors là j'ai quand même
répondu je me suis expliqué voilà alors
j'ai pas dit que je voulais pas me faire
vacciner
j'ai dit ce qui est vrai que j'ai des
examens médicaux a passé et que selon
les résultats je verrai puis à la fin
j'ai fait l'innocent depuis jeudi mais
en fait je croyais que c'etait pas
obligatoire